our first guest wrote in with a special
request ruby ortiz is an 11th grade
spanish teacher in brooklyn but today
she's putting down the textbooks and
picking up the microphone
to be our co-host for the day ruby
welcome
[Applause]
well drew i'm really excited to be here
um i love watching your show after a
long day of work i mean i love your for
stain segments you've helped me remove
so many stains i love it you host so
many fabulous celebrities i love to be
here
i hope that by being here i can show my
students that you can do anything you
put your mind to and i'm excited to get
started and ready to be here
well
we sent you home last night
with a whole bunch of what we call
dossiers
which just sounds like oprah winfrey
meets the fbi
um
it's like on our show we have a lot of
information on everyone who comes
everything goes into these dossiers so
we gave you our homework packet last
night you did i'm ready i've studied my
notes and i'm ready for today all right
then you and me both all right well
let's head over to the news desk to hit
the headlines
okay it's time for truth news your daily
tip of the good news cap and with me at
the desk is one of the finest fellows in
news ross matthews
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh this is so fun i love kicking off the
show with the news i know and we got a
lot to talk about today so here we go
first up fans of the classic horror
movie franchise halloween are freaking
out because the new movie comes out
friday i know halloween kills stars the
legendary scream queen jamie lee curtis
and of course the always creepy michael
meyer
no one's more excited than a little
four-year-old girl named arya
she recently went viral because she was
simply over the moon when michael myers
crashed her birthday what
look at this yeah oh she loves him
apparently
and he's her favorite character
um i don't know how in the hell she
found out about him in the first place
um
but uh yeah
rossi what would you do if michael myers
showed up to your birthday i'd be
chucking cupcakes is what i'd be doing
get out of here you know i don't like
scary movies okay the
the scariest movie i ever watched was
mrs doubtfire i don't like anything
worse than that
this little girl can we get her a barney
something like this is freaky no ma'am
no no no
do you know what's really funny is my
daughter frankie loves it
that movie it she well not the movie
because i don't want her to watch the
movie what is it it's that clown who's
the killer out i'm out i gotta go nope
nope and she knows he's dark but like
she also loves cemetery she's a little
macabre you know what i mean
ruby are you a horror movie fan i'm not
i'm with ross i am not a fan
um i ca i can't sit through a scary
movie i'm jumping every five seconds i
can't my heart's racing ruby and i will
be in the corner watching pretty woman
on a list
thank you yes we will well speaking of
halloween classics tim burton's the
nightmare before christmas have you seen
it
well
and then you're in luck it's going to be
turned into a live concert film event
this month and people reports that the
beloved character of sally will be
performed by none other than
billy eilish
my favorite
great casting my hero my favorite yeah
she's going to be phenomenal in this and
she'll perform with the incredible danny
elfman reprising jack skellington and um
you've seen this right you like
nightmare before christmas
i do love this movie um big tim burton
fan i would say my favorite tim burton
movie probably still to this day is
edward scissorhands oh yeah
and beetlejuice i love beetlejuice i
auditioned for beetlejuice wait timeout
you auditioned for beetlejuice oh i
auditioned for everything the um the
main character winona yes wow
i have i've auditioned for every movie
out there really absolutely
oh i have so many when i was a kid yeah
what one killed you the most that you
didn't get
um
gosh that's a good question
i i don't know i mean they were
i auditioned for cape fear
i told that story yeah like i i just
that's what happens you know you just
try out for everything well i'm still
upset they didn't cast me as james bond
but you know what i move on
got over it
i should say yet they haven't cast me
yet as james bond they're looking for a
new one
oh that's a double oh no
um well we've got some good news
from the golden arches in today's green
news
[Applause]
i'm
i'm very excited about this pbs reports
that mcdonald's has made a pledge to
drastically cut the use of plastics in
happy meal toys yes
i love this
by 2025 they will use 90 percent less
plastic and they're already phasing in
toys made of cardboard and plant-based
plastics and also by 2025 all of their
food packaging will be in sustainable
and fully recyclable boxes oh this is
great
i say this a lot but i'm going to keep
saying it i am scared that we will not
make this deadline to save our planet
and when the big companies step in and
say they're going to make the changes i
get hopeful yeah because we have to make
our individual um you know
efforts but it feels futile when the big
companies are doing it a different way
so thank you mcdonald's thank you thank
you thank you i very much as one citizen
really appreciate it yeah i do too and i
have to say i was a little hesitant
though because this is great that
they're doing this but here's a nugget
of advice to mcdonald's you gotta you
gotta keep them cool right because when
i was a little kid i would go to town on
a happy meal for that toy and i have to
say we have some of them right here
well done mcdonald's they're cool all
right
look at this it's cute it's all paper
i'd be excited about this listen this is
just good news i'm into it me too um
yeah but just keep them cool like this
okay i'm hitting burger king
got it
well we have a new segment alert we're
trying something brand new today we
asked you what we should review and we
got so many good responses so now it's
time for the first ever installment of
drew's reviews
[Applause]
oh it's warm
i swear ross is going to kill me every
every day i show up there's a different
carbohydrate here waiting for us to eat
i am trying to keep it together drew i
know i'm sorry and i was on a diet too
and now i'm what are you gonna do come
um well today our pick comes from rachel
osland on instagram it's trader joe's
pumpkin caramel kringle now apparently
the kringle is a trader joe's specialty
but only during this special time of
year can you get it in the pumpkin
flavor by the way i'm salivating
okay
how much did you eat did you lick it
rossi did you take a ladybite i
took
a petite nibble thank you very much i
served a giant mouthful of you know
you know what it's giving me in a great
way like maple bar
mm-hmm it's giving me um cinnamon roll
mm-hmm yeah it's like the two of those
mated i'm not mad about it
wow this is really good thank you so
much um rachel for asking us to try yet
another delicious tasty treat here on
the news
um you know i guess in if you're doing a
review you should rate it all right how
you wanna do it i think it's like what
is it five stars is the best mm-hmm
i'm gonna go four and a half wow
wow
that's a big review
it's so wonderful all right well please
please please write in your reviews we'd
love to try fun stuff and give it a
review we'll be right back
[Music]
you